anyway joining us now we have Miranda
Devine she of course wrote the
best-selling book the laptop from Hell
Greg Jarrett Fox News legal analyst
thank you both Miranda let's get your
take on all of this because to me the
walls are caving in on this Biden very
real bribery and money laundering uh
Scandal accusations
recently
that Victor shoken we're starting to
look at him again and realize that the
story that was fed to the World by Joe
Biden and his handmaidens in the media
was just one side of the story and
probably false we know at least half of
it was false we were told that Victor
shokun was corrupt well Joe Biden nobody
has ever produced any evidence to prove
that he was and in fact he was a very
popular uh
prosecutor of you know a career
prosecutor of many decades he had lots
of high-profile scalps and the Ukrainian
people thought that he was a bit of a
hero and he was reluctantly dragooned
into being prosecuted General and he was
setting about doing what he was supposed
to do which was tackling corruption he
was tackling verisma we know that he
seized barisma's the owners of barisma's
properties just a month before he was
fired and so he you know it was a lie
that the barisma investigation was
dormant which was one of the other
reasons we were told why shoken had to
go he only had 10 months in the job
before Joe Biden started making these
black male attempts these overbearing
bullying attempts to get rid of him and
uh you know you can only assume that
there must have been something for Joe
Biden that he went above and beyond What
government policy was at that time by
withholding a billion dollars in usaid
and that's the story that ended up
getting Donald Trump impeached he got
impeached for what Joe Biden had done
wrong
Greg Jarrett we also have an
acknowledgment by the National Archives
and Records administration of 5400
emails that they have of Joe Biden as
vice president using a pseudonym email
using pseudonym email accounts oh I
can't wait to see what's in those emails
I'm sure they were only talking about
the weather
yeah
5400 uh you know Alias emails that were
sent uh many of them to his son who
allegedly forwarded them to his overseas
business partners look I think the
impeachment of Joe Biden seems
increasingly inevitable and there's more
than enough evidence to justify as
Miranda indicated the barisma scam alone
Falls squarely under the bribery statute
of using your public office to confer a
benefit in exchange for money to your
son and family you know these newly
revealed documents actually corroborate
Victor shokun's statements that you know
Joe and Hunter were knee-deep in bribery
engineered is firing to end the
investigation of barisma which was pain
Hunter a million dollars a year a
staggering sum I mean shokun was
actually in the process of seizing the
CEO's assets he was going to shut down
the company so barisma pressured Hunter
to pressure as far father to get rid of
shoken and documents in Devin Archer
confirm it and when shokun was canned
the probe vanished magically overnight
and then the cash continued to flow to
Hunter so you know it doesn't matter if
Joe received a penny because under the
law if the money goes to another person
or entity other than the office holder
that's still bribery and that is an
impeachable offense
all right Greg Jarrett Miranda thank you
both we appreciate it hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else